hey everybody and welcome to a hopeful
wild ride with sto we've got the legend
Gary ve who was born in one of the
poorest places in the world immigrated
to America and made himself a humongous
success from nothing and the hope that
he shares with us in his advice for
people to go from having nothing to
having a lot is really inspiring man
plus he's just a lot of fun a humble guy
a good guy maybe actually the best guy
and it's just a great time that we had
with him so everybody get ready to be
inspired get ready to have hope get
ready for Gary Vee let's get into
it people of the Universe I bring to you
Gary
V what's up Universe yeah dude I decided
to go woke
are you woke
no not not even but uh but ladies and
gentlemen it occurred to me you know
leave some people out and while I don't
want to be woke I do want to include
absolutely everybody I love that so so
that's why you're doubling down on
Universe yeah yeah yeah everybody in the
universe yeah sure all shapes and yeah
all you little [__] like uh oh steo
woke like suck a fart out of my butthole
and chill out like uh we're we're light
we're easy we're having a good time and
this is Gary V good to meet you pleasure
brother real pleasure to meet you
honestly you're real legend thank you
for having me you guys are about the
same age yeah how old are you I'm 49
yeah I just turned 48 you 46 Jesus
Christ 40 40 sorry it's a lot of gray
you look phenomenal if I now that I've
now that you react that way and I'm
looking closer to the skin I might have
went 38 but if if the gray was black
you're 30 no
D I know I'm yeah yeah of course it's
just harder to hear that I I I met up
with Simon Eddie at the at the wedding
and uh he's like are you 50 now I'm like
[__] though it's just it's normal
human behavior the gray over indexes it
and but the cool part is you're fully in
control like you're you mean I have my
hair well yes which is amazing I think
what it's saying is you're in control
it's not too late to some to move your
body yeah it's not too L to put down the
pasta I know but I bet you equally you
get good compliments on the Silver Fox
thing yeah well yeah so you're just what
I'm saying it's the choice of going bald
or gray I'd rather go gray a
th% 100% the question is do you want to
color it green no black no and then
you're [__] I enjoy going Silver Fox but
you're going to get some 44s instead of
38s for sometimes even yeah sometimes
whoever that which is crazy cuz the face
is too baby but that's nothing 44 and 38
same [__] yeah I'm at the age where like
uh people are starting to like Mis guess
my age and I'm like oh [__] it's
happening I'm getting older well the
worst part was when you you know we're
all going through this you're still a
youngster like that flip where like you
know like I me and a lot of my friends
were babyfaced so when we were like 26
you'd go to Vegas and you get card you
be like yeah you still got it all of a
sudden you're like 34 and they like you
40 you're like well what just happened
why did I just age 20 years in a
seven-year window yeah age is undefeated
fellas that's correct man and and I I
could stand to uh put down some food and
and move my body around a little bit too
I'm oh I got it I think at 40 it it
becomes more of a health issue than like
a vanity issue yeah because you know I I
was at Dr Drew's house today how that
and I I love Dr Drew and I think we we
should get him back on but but that's
another conversation for another time
and uh uh with with Gary ve now not
um candidly yes Gary you're you're
so uh specialized in in uh business
being an entrepreneur financial success
and and we've always enjoyed speaking
with our guests about like what what
their various revenue streams you know
like I'd love to hear guest top three
revenue streams without being inv about
numbers but
uh you want me to answer it
or
yeah you never asked so I think I think
I operate and invest and so what I mean
by that is I actively am always running
a company from you know from my
childhood from being 22 to 34 I did that
for my dad's liquor store those were not
super successful Financial Years cuz I
was building the company for him and we
were an immigrant family and you don't
get paid a lot but it was epic and one
of my Great accomplishments so when I
say I operate and I invest right now I'm
the CEO of a company called vayer X
Vayner media is the big company in that
I love this yeah a modern day
communications company so basically
Madmen 2023 my company does the
marketing for companies like Pepsi and
Chase and all these Fanatics and all
these big Brands and we do different
[__] some people we do all the social
media content some people we do the
Super Bowl commercial we killed Mr
Peanut oh wow we were the agency that
worked on Planters when we killed Mr
peut during the Super it's an ad agency
but it's 2024 version almost every
client we work with we're like do you
understand how important it is to do
social media right you know that kind of
stuff I mean this is actually very meta
liquid death yeah started by Mike the
jobby had while he was building liquid
death was at bayner media in La wow sent
me an emails like I'm ready to do do my
own thing do you want to invest I'm like
yeah I wanted to support him well he's a
good dude I was like here's a couple
bucks I'm going to make a [__]
fortune on it cuz he's a beast and he
built liquid death he Mike cerio is a
very very impressive guy the CEO of
liquid that's right and literally the
job the second before he was the CEO of
liquid death he was a creative director
at Vayner media La no kidding yeah he is
absolutely a creative director have you
heard of hot sauce for your butthole do
you want this to explode and you want me
to help you out make yeah honestly no
[__] honestly no bull [__] it would
be great enjoyment whether right after
this podcast if we got a couple minutes
or let's get on Zoom the joy I would
have to tell you to do six or seven
different things to quadruple the [__]
out of this business would be a great
pleasure of
mine you don't have to say that twice
yeah happy to do it so anyway uh I don't
want to be wrong winded I'm always
driving something Vayner media the other
thing I do is vriends which is like my
Pokemon meets uh Marvel meets Sesame
Street an intellectual property nfts
trading cards apparel um coming out with
animations uh here you can see it so
vriends is really exciting for me you
guys are quite creative so you can
imagine how exciting this is for me like
literally as a baseball card collectible
comicbook kid I can't believe I actually
have like I can go on eBay right now and
go to completed actually you guys are
doing this here if you go on eBay and go
to completed items like it's crazy to me
if you type in B now I saw you make a
post about your V friends and you said
that you were going to make it as big as
Pokemon that's right and that might let
me let me clar like and even sometimes I
need to do a better job Clear for the
next 50 years I'd like to make it as yep
keep scrolling you're good whoever this
is Beast there it is completed and sold
hit them both there you go look this is
[__] like I just got to say as someone
who like has been on eBay since 1998 and
just loves garage selling and finding
[__] and buying [__] and pop cultures
why I [__] with you heavy like looking
at this like blows my I [__] Drew
these things three years years ago and
now it's like a full pledge real thing
okay we're looking at trading cards at
the moment trading cards that sold on
eBay um and which is distinctly
different from nfts you know what's
funny I I think wildly not different but
I get where you're going I understand
fungible and non-fungible very smart
well nft is strictly digital correct
correct yeah okay I I was telling my dad
yes that that like My Philosophy or my
understanding of nfts that it's like
here like anybody that wants to bring it
up on the internet technically can have
it but the person who uh who buys the
nft actually owns it that's right I said
Dad this is like uh Talent telling a
woman you know yeah like any woman in
the world can have my wiener
but my wi actually
yours okay yeah that makes so much more
sens that was how you got your dad to
understand yeah just like that's my way
of saying anybody can have it but like
one person supposed to like have
ownership of it it just sounds like just
it's absurd it sounds so you view if
you're in a relationship that person
owns your penis right yeah like but even
though even though the rest of the world
has access to it do they I mean that it
would be wrong if they ask nicely buy
you a couple drinks that that would be
wrong so anyway these are the two
companies run I also do you know so
let's talk about it every year is
different because I do a lot of
investing so obviously one day liquid
death will sell to Pepsi or Coke yeah
and I'll get a check for that investment
yeah have soon do you think that's going
to
happen are you an investor yeah nice uh
I I don't know uh I I'm sure at this
point anybody with you know between that
and Prime energy drink there's some big
beverages running around there that are
independent that I'm sure the Cokes and
the Pepsis and the biggest companies are
looking at I think next 2 three year
you'll see more more m&a activity but
the place I make my most dollars is
being the CEO of Vayner media it's a
2,000 person $300 million plus business
I'm the founder operator so that's that
world that's in Vader X um this I mean
speaking is big for me stebo okay good
yeah I'm a I'm a I'm a pretty
substantial public speaker and like my
fee is pretty bananas and if when I
we're getting close enough to the end of
the year that may be the second biggest
place of my
Revenue you know why that doesn't
surprise me because Gary ve believes in
himself and he bets on himself and if
you're inclined to bet on anything then
let me tell you about draft King
Sportsbook the official betting partner
of the UFC because they are so excited
about this weekend's UFC 296 it is the
most incredible card ever I don't know
how they're going to beat this for UFC
300 but let me tell you draftking sports
book is is going to give you
$150 in bonus bets instantly if you bet
so much as five bucks on this
unbelievable card it's Colby Covington
versus Leon Edwards I mean from top to
bottom the card is so unbelievably
stacked like ridiculous Ian Gary I mean
dude Patty pimblett Tony Ferguson to
Wonderboy Thompson shop cot ranov dude
it's it's like I can't even stand it
it's going to be so awesome and if
you're going to bet on the fights then
do it with draft King sports book One
More Time download the app draftking
Sportsbook app and use the promo code
steo to enjoy
$150 in bonus bets immediately as soon
as you bet so much as five bucks on UFC
296 gambling problem call- 1800 Gambler
or visit www.1 1800 gambler. net in New
York call 8778 Hope and Y or text Hope
and Y to 467 369 in Connecticut help is
available for problem gambling call 888
78977 77 or visit ccpg please play
responsibly on behalf of booill Casino
and Resort KS 21 plus age varies by
jurisdiction void in Ontario bonus bets
expire 168 hours after issuance see
Sports book. draftkings.com MMA terms
for eligibility and deposit restrictions
terms and responsible gaming resources
unbelievable now let's get back to it
this so you book your um your speaking
engagements which would be considered a
personal appearance that's right uh with
an agent so I was with ca for a long
time and then 5 years ago I started my
own speaking bureau Vayner speakers wow
so if you're looking to make you know I
can make you some money on the sauce I
can make you some money on the speaking
there you go yeah you have a story this
is turning out to be a really good you
no you know I'm I'm I'm fascinated with
your you said you have a very big
speaking fee yes but that wasn't always
the case does that come with a
self-worth thing or like no supply and
demand of of of it's a great question do
I think people whether they're doing
standup comedy whether they're doing
anything you know cutting hair you can
cut it for 12 bucks you can cut it for
50 like sure there's that game of do you
know what you're asking for but the
market is the market like when I first
started 34 years old really speaking
well I had pretty good confidence I'm
like I really think I'm good but the
market hadn't said that I was worth what
I'm worth now okay so I think it's just
supplying to me un you know speaking is
funny and personal appearance is funny
for the human and you've been through
this and for people who go through it or
think about it it seems crazy that you
could be compensated so well for a short
period of time but in reality there's
something happening on the back end so I
could be like oh my God I'm getting
[__] flown to Madrid and I'm going to
speak for an hour and it's I can't
believe the economics I'm making it's
not like the world is Puffy ideological
yay yay the organizers of that event in
Spain are making money on the fact that
I'm there for sure you know and so it's
it's very much supply and demand sell
for's a good question do I believe a lot
of people list right now mowing lungs
cutting hair public speaking Super
Famous not known at all doing a service
business do I think most people don't
know how to ask for a little more money
the next time to keep upping their fee
yes I do and I'm glad you asked that
question um when I go do a podcast like
this I'm like okay this is [__] an
epic show with icons I'm going to come
on we're going to talk about our subject
matter but like if I can leave in like
three to seven people hear one little
tidbit and all whatever the [__] we chop
up at and it becomes a good thing for
them like the thought that somebody
right now actually that does something
he's like yeah [__] and like they charge
100 bucks for whatever the [__] we're
talking about right babysitting 12 bucks
an hour and tomorrow the neighbor goes
how much are you and you're like $15 an
hour because you listen to this and they
say yes then we had a good [__]
podcast that's great people will say you
know I know and by the way people will
say no and don't change your price back
to $12 an hour get 10 Nos and then
you're like okay I'm delusional my big
thing is get 10 NOS before you go back
down too many people like are scared to
go up try one time someone says no and
they're like see [__] Gary I was
always 12 yeah you get what you paid for
it yeah I'm glad that you said that too
because when I initially was saying you
know what I started to say I was uh
going to express a sensitivity that uh
speaking to my audience you know about
like like I wanted to make it relatable
to people and you just did that for me
well see honestly no [__] like I've
got lots of passions but and I lots of
things I want to talk about but you know
I'm very selective of what I do and when
I do it I always think it's only about
them like I don't need people skipping
this podcast for you I don't want to
[__] you up I don't want people to be
like that suck that's not for me if you
can't make it contextual and relatable
to who's actually going to listen then
what the [__] are we doing here right
like I'm more than capable of trying to
build my own audience on my channels I
think when you go into someone's home
you take off the shoes you know what I
mean like to me the only thing I'm
thinking about right now is how to
respect y'all and more importantly even
more than you is your audience and so
like look take me wherever you think I
can bring value but the good news is
like I'm aware of y'all and I'm a fan
and like I I like and more importantly
like cool I'm a businessman but like
like I'm also a human being like what do
you think me and my buddies did in
Jersey in the 80s and 90s dumb [__] and
like you guys are legends to us they're
like oh [__] all the dumb [__] we were
doing is like real like that so like
this is fun to be with you cool I love
it thank you for that um what's the
probably very blurry line like uh what
vayer media yes um an ad agency and a
production company my God so we have a
production company you can pull this one
up Eva Noam Eva Noam how do you remember
all these names it's two separate words
they'll probably Eva space Noam noad Dam
Eva space here we go there we go it's
there um
so this is Madison a spelled backwards
ah um this is our production company for
our commercials in New York in New York
in LA and I own this as well this is
part of Vayner X Vayner media is the
agency even Noam is the production
company now to your point the world you
grew up in production was heavy like big
[__] it was real and so our commercials
our Super Bowl we do here our agency as
the creative Department they're also
producing actual social media ads so
that's the twist that we did to the
industry forever 70 years you had an ad
agency that came up with the ideas and
then that's what you got paid for and
then there was a production company that
would make this merch Madness by little
baty B that we did for Fanatics we still
do that as you can see here with ianos
Sadam and Vayner media but inside of
Vayner media the ad firm everybody in
Creative also makes social media
creative and that was the Twist and
that's how we changed the industry is
one of your uh contemporaries or your
rival
at um Vayner media a company called
sharability are you familiar with them
yes I think that got brought up to me
the other day um um maybe um one thing I
don't do it's either my strength or my
weakness I'm almost oblivious to
competition good Blue Ocean strategy
yeah I've heard that as well what is
that it's just like there's no
competition there's no red in the
there's no blood in the Water by the way
I love competition like if you guys were
like let's thumb wrestle I'd get like
super serious right now yeah yeah but
you have the mindset there's like enough
for everybody it's AB it and by the way
if somebody's like wins something you're
absolutely I don't think that they took
it out of me I by the way that includes
like we're in a pitch right now for
we're not but I'm going to use it
because I love them if we're in a pitch
for New Balance yeah and we're against
droga 5 and sharability and wiid and
Kennedy and we're it's four of us and we
lose I'm aware that one of those three
people won but that's the micro in the
macro I'm going to get mine for sure
we're good enough honestly weirdly I
even like when other people first of all
I kind of weirdly like losing like I'm
like you know there's a level of like
leaning into your own humility and like
you should never always win and the
Merit and trying to figure out how to
get better at it um but yeah blue ocean
defin for me it's always abundance for
sure it's like nobody's stopping me but
myself if I spend a minute trying to
figure out what everybody else is doing
that's a minute I'm not figuring out the
consumer and I don't have time for that
nonsense um okay so let's uh take some
that being said in your world Vay watt
Vayner v a y n r
wt.com this one I'm excited about this
is a new company for me about a year old
now and this is maybe some way we Jam
together in the future so we started a
production company good and so this is a
production company not for commercials
scripted unscripted the guy that left
there Eric wattenberg it was at ca for
20 years then he did wheelhouse for the
last five or six years and we've teamed
up and we're just now
pitching our shows that's pretty fun I
like it um for for somebody who uh
doesn't know what they want to do who
isn't even necessarily employed yes you
know H having financial difficulty like
what is your take on that well what is
your advice for like absolutely zero to
roof over your head it's the reason I
started
making garage sale videos so you could
pull up Trash Talk Gary ve I'm just I
you could see I'm getting addicted with
this it's pretty [__] awesome I might
need to live like this so um this this
lady was amazing anyway I this is my
advice so I started getting those emails
and I was like you know what so for the
people listening I I have a good back to
different audience across I know a good
amount may not know who I am I grew up I
was born in the Soviet Union I was born
in the USSR bellus thank you my man so I
came here when I was three we lived in a
studio apartment the size of this
[__] van with like five six family
members like real humble beginnings and
so you know I didn't grow up with much
and you know in my teenage years I I
started going to garage sales and then
going to the flea market and flipping
[__] I was always into like Collectibles
that's why the vprs thing is fun and all
that and then when my brother's 11 years
younger than me when my brother was like
13 I could tell my mom was trying to
make him a lawyer I'm like no no no like
AJ come with me we're going to go garage
sing and now this new thing eBay I'm
going to we're going to sell it on this
thing mhm and
so how old were you I was 22 at that
time or 23 at that time when I was
teaching my brother that's when eBay had
just come out a few years earlier and I
watched my brother go from zero to like
$10,000 in cash in in a summer because
we would buy video games for 50 cents
and sell them for 20 bucks on eBay or a
shirt or anything nostalgic pop culture
things like that so my advice is first
of all I'm going to go Mac and micro in
the micro right now in America and
obviously it's in some other parts of
the world but garage sailing is bigger
here in America the quickest way to go
from
$20 to your name to 10,000 which creates
some sort of breathing room of some
sorts I genuinely believe is thrift
stores and garage sales genuinely
because because it's a place where you
can buy things for a quarter 50 cents in
a dollar and get 20 you can't do that in
many other yeah but I feel like like the
G for sure you're right but if you're
starting out at a thrift store on
Melrose no no [__] way that's that's
bougie thrift store I'm talking Goodwill
like you can go to the Goodwill it's
very interesting it's very interesting
all over the country yeah I bought some
cool STS and [__] in Oklahoma at the
thrift store like and these are like
brick and mortar places where you can go
and purchase something for like 50 cents
a dollar and then but then you take it
online and you you've got such an
infinitely larger audience yeah and and
it's not even your audience for was
listening like [__] I don't have an
audience no no no you just listed on
eBay you just list it on post Poshmark
you just list it on these places marari
there's all these places now so
a0000 the most logical place I see is
garage sales so so it's the tales oldest
time is like get a product and sell it
that's the one like I think about this a
lot because somewhere along the line I
kept telling the stories about like
early in my career after I which was 10
15 years into my career after I saved
some money I made these good investments
in 2006 they were called Facebook
Twitter and Tumblr and of course it
changed my life and I would talk a lot
about it talking but then I just started
getting enough emails saying like yo bro
I [__] with you Gary I love you but like
I don't have $25,000 to put in some sort
of startup so what do I do and finally
after because I read all my DMs and
email especially back in 07 8 9 10 11 I
was really doing it cuzz I could manage
it I was like [__] they're right I got
to talk about some other [__] yeah and
that's how I got to this and so to
answer the question in the micro I
believe the answer genuinely is garage
sale flipping are you still doing garage
sailing to this day yeah that's me like
a couple weeks ago now at this point I'm
donating what I buy and what I sell for
the charity because I'm in this place of
my life but no [__] bro like
honestly I like doing that [__] more
than almost anything I do in life let me
tell you something straight up as
excited as Gary V gets about garage
sales I think my lady Lux gets a lot
more excited when she finds out I've
taken a blue chew tablet because that
means her and I are about to have a good
old time why because bluechew tablets
have the same active ingredient as both
Viagra and Calis except they're
delicious chewable and they only cost a
fraction of the price and if you think
that taking a blue chw tablet might be a
lot of fun then you're on to something
because I have a whole lot of fun when I
do it and get this for the listeners of
the Wild Ride podcast you can get an
entire month supply of Bluetooth tablets
absolutely for free all you pay is five
bucks for shipping I mean come on you go
on bluechew.com and consult with the
medical provider on their website it's
very easy it's very quick and that takes
care of your prescription and once
you've done that boom you plug in the
promo code steo and that unlocks an
entire month supply of Bluetooth tablets
all you pay is five bucks for shipping
you can't beat it and I recommend trying
it so jump on that deal at bluechew.com
with the promo code steo and let's get
back to
it here okay so so this is great and and
the problem with most people is they're
not motivated yeah that's right and and
like I I I had a a product in 2006 that
I was selling in retail I invented this
thing and I sold it and uh go man don't
do that tell them what it is so I
invented a workout towel a workout towel
the vcco pocket so you can keep all your
[__] in there while you go to the gym to
Safe towel safe like so so I don't it's
not even around anymore but
uh people I mean it's it's it's a
standard go to the gym and you know like
I totally understand that was the by the
way that was the easiest thing to
understand of all time that was smart
you fixed you fixed the micro pain yeah
I would like that's smart but my my
theory was people were like how did you
do it it's like I think any product is a
good product it just depends on how
passionate that person is because and
how do you execute and how yeah of
course that but and how much drugs
you're doing and how much drugs you're
doing at the time always a correlation
but but but the hardest part for me is
like so back in 2006 I stopped listening
to music when I was driving I listen to
motivational books to keep myself that
hungry and happy now now now you're
talking about why Gary ve exists right
like so I was going to answer it in the
macro and I love you for going to where
this is all about people being
comfortable in their own skin not
everybody to your point let me tell you
something about me I'm motivated when
we're talking about business I'm
motivated when we're talking about
kindness or like people skills I'm not
motivated when you're talking about
filling out a
form wow like I'm in serious no no I'm
going to say this nice and slow I am
borderline incapable of administrative
duties of administrative duties yeah
yeah
I'm cuz we're creative yeah look for
everybody who's
listening if you do not understand
yourself and you're listening to [__]
like me or your mom or your dad or your
buddy and they're like just you can't do
that that's like telling me like just
shut the [__] up I can't I need to talk
like we have to reverse engineer truth
mhm so to your point when I put out all
these videos the comments are like yeah
but the gas cost 20 bucks I'm like but I
made $800 they're like yeah but the eBay
fees I'm like yeah but I made $800 but
those are just the the weakest people
that aren't survival of the fittest like
it's not you don't have that drive to do
that then what's interesting about that
and I see where you're going is I'm
fascinated by what the internet does to
change the variable of how many don't
have to be the
weakest the option I'll give you good
example of this in culture right now
everyone wants a [__] on jenzy mhm
entitled lazy this that and like there's
plenty of that like look when the
government prints unlimited amounts of
money during Co and gives it to people
for staying home it [__] up people yeah
like it confuses people about Merit that
being said when I hear like some
entrepreneurs tell me like Gary this
[__] gen Z I'm like bro you're asking
them to work for $3 an hour for 10 hours
a day in your [__] store I got news
for you a lot of these kids know how to
make $230 a day in Tik Tok ads like they
could sell some T like there's these
kids have options MH like like sorry
they don't want to work at Kmart for
eight bucks an hour for 53 hours a week
like I don't blame them if they know how
to make it a different way they're going
to yeah and so what what is that what
was all that about that was about
there's a lot of options and I think
there's a lot of people right now who
are listening to us with a blunt in hand
and chilling and saying like yeah I'm
just not Mo I'm just chill I'm just
chill my argument is yeah but there's
some [__] you give a [__] about
something music something yeah and by
the way this is so [__] meta you and
your crew that wasn't monetizable 20
years earlier it's true it's very true
you guys became famous and Rich doing
[__] that you couldn't become famous and
Rich for 20 years earlier than when you
did it and they had to get somebody to
say yes the internet is like yo I'm here
I'm open for business what do you want
now the problem is the internet is also
Fair meaning when people are like Gary
I'm [__] Shadow banned on social
media I'm not doing well I'm like bro
you're not Shadow banned you just
suck like everyone's always got an
excuse like yo [__] instagam do you
think Shadow band's a real thing though
sh so you you think Shadow band doesn't
not real for 1% of 1% it's not real for
the guy who's been posting the same [__]
for 20 weeks and nobody gives a [__] and
he's like I'm Shadow banned I'm like
you're not Shadow band nobody thinks
you're funny yeah and so and bro on some
real [__] love when my content doesn't
do well when I post something and it
underperforms literally I'm like yep
[__] you Gary you thought it was good
they didn't learn next yeah so the
Internet isn't necessarily Fair it's
just highly Democratic yes and the
blockchain's even more Dem you know the
internet's got its variables things work
differently but here's the punchline
most things are more fair than people
want to think people want to blame a
president people want to blame their
parents people want to people want to
blame blame blame we've gotten
remarkable at pointing fingers nobody
wants to do this [__] for sure people
have like almost cut their [__]
thumbs off like people don't want to do
this [__] Steve like guys like and to me
I'm not trying to be like motivational
or rough it's just very very obvious to
me there's a direct correlation of
happiness and
accountability I love that yeah that's
that I love that I've I've Loved a lot
of things that you said that's my
favorite thing so far than well that's
what Chang my life was when I went
through the step work and you like
what's my part in it and you start
getting into the habit of like looking
at every problem in your life and being
like Oh I [__] let me be vulnerable
here a little bit I I've done well but
like you know at five six years ago I
was like hey this is me talking to
myself hey if you're such a nice dude
and like you don't care about the money
and you really give a [__] about your
employees hey dude why then are there
people that used to work for you that
don't like you you see that little
Facebook group where they [__] on you
forign employees you've seen some of
these things that they said you've
gotten emails from people that had the
courage to tell you to your face why so
I did the work you know I kept cuz it
bothered me I'm like man I really want
to be nice I really think I'm nice like
what am I doing wrong and finally enough
things happened both personally and
professionally where I'm like oh Gary ve
in a podcast with y'all he's canderous
because he's not actually talking to
anyone he's talking to everyone okay but
if I cared about you I struggled to
deliver cander believe it or not Gary
PUK the businessman my whole life I
would have very sloppy firings cuz I
couldn't cuz I become friends with my
employees right and then when you had to
get like if something wasn't working for
a long time it would be like all [__]
up and I didn't tell them along the way
like maybe occasionally I'd say
something but now the last five six
years there's like a real process to how
I do it like if six months in it's not
working I I have the strength now to sit
down in front of somebody I like and say
hey Johnny hey Susan like this not
working let me tell you what you're
doing wrong cuz there was still time to
fix it right I wasn't over the bubble of
resentment but you know and so like I
get yet like being accountable I sit
here and out loud say to all the people
that have ever worked for me or
interacted with me where I had to fire
them where they're like what the [__]
dude last week you were saying
everything was great and I'm like you're
right like I wasn't strong enough yet
one-on-one to be able to talk about it
because I thought I was scaring you but
I thought I hate fear are you a people
pleaser yes but not that bad it's more
that I hate fear and I thought if I sat
someone down and said hey shit's not
going well that they'd be scared they go
home that night and drink and cry and go
on LinkedIn and try to find a new job
and it wasn't about that yet I was
trying to find different ways to help
them but the lack of cander created a
vulnerability and then ultimately
especially if I had to let them go and I
wasn't able to figure out a different
way without ever telling them which I
did a lot but a lot I didn't it became
sloppy and I regret it and I and I own
it and it sucks but I try to be better
now how many people you think you
fired thousands I mean I've employed you
know lots and lots of people like you
know probably 10,000 people have been
employed at Vayner through the years the
wine store probably had hundreds and
hundreds it's definitely thousand I you
know and and I directly had to do
hundreds not thousands but but but at
the end of the day I always say to my
people this is just true Everything At
Vayner media my companies is my fault
and by the way at Vayner media everybody
who gets fired I have to sign off on
just to make sure my managers are not
[__] [__] up so at the end of the day
it's still my decision the the I heard a
guy say that like he was a CEO that
fired a lot of people and he said you
know the one pattern that I found out uh
that was consistent was as soon as you
get that thought of like oh this
person's got to go he's like they're
he's like and you you won't fire them
because you feel bad or whatever you
give them a chance he's like within
three months they should he's like
that's the point where they should have
been gone already yeah that there's a
lot of Truth to that I think what we've
gotten better at in our company I've
been surprised how many people have been
refurbished we call it kind cander if
you're able to with compassion tell not
hey Johnny you suck you better get your
act together we'll you better get your
[__] together see you next week you know
like no no if you're like hey style
there's a great boxing term Styles make
fights Y what it really means for
everybody who's listening is you could
have the two best boxers in the world
fight each other but because
stylistically the way they were all of
us as fans could be bored for 12 rounds
you see in UFC as well styles styles
make fights I use that a lot with people
I'm like hey Styles make fights just cuz
it's not working from the subjective
opinion of me and four or five of your
bosses it doesn't mean we're right
doesn't mean we're wrong it's six people
that think you're [__] up yeah but
that doesn't mean you suck like it just
means maybe you're not doing the right
thing here now what I've been surprised
about is some people are like whoa I
might get F like actually it changes
them it changes them but other people
we've changed we've changed positions
within the company other people are like
you know what I it's actually beautiful
when you can do K caner had a dude
recently say you know what Gary I've
been wanting to write like I need to
write I need to write right and like
this you know obviously I pay my bills
with all this but like this is the sign
I needed like I know I'm not showing up
proper this year cuz I've been
distracted because I'm writing because
it's work from home and I'm probably not
working most of the time right and he
was just honest about it I was like cool
bro like love like it's not so back to
Blue Ocean I don't view my employees as
my property as my competitors like bad I
view them as family and sometimes you
have [__] [__] that's not working out
and it's okay MH yeah what about hiring
family members I believe in it you
believe you ever had a fire family
member um not really but I've had to
have like conversation like to me the
reason I like hiring family members is
first of all my dad has fired both me
and my sister so big shout out to Sasha
vaynerchuk who has no problem firing
family members
um uh I got fired for one day my sister
permanently sorry Liz um I think that uh
to me I like I think people tell you
know that old saying right don't hire
family or friends yeah I think it's a
mistake I think it works a lot I think
if now I would say 48-year-old Gary is
far more should hire family and friends
now than 25-year-old Gary because the
lack of cander led to resentment and
awkwardness so I think it comes down to
do you believe you and the person you're
hiring has a communication structure and
what I've always done with family is I'm
like listen to me I am running this
business for everyone and I can't create
an
nepotism and I can't [__] it up and
there may be a Darkhorse chance where
this doesn't work out and you just
overcommunication
story CU I hope this helps someone you
ready for some good news well whether
Gary's little story helps anybody or not
the sponsor of today's episode is
definitely helping people because it's
betterhelp.com better help is an online
service which matches people with
licensed professional therapists they do
it very well and they make getting into
therapy convenient easy private it just
happens online and I'll tell you I
believe in therapy a whole lot myself I
do it to protect my relationship with
Lux because I subscribe to the
philosophy it's better to fix the roof
before it rains how about that and man
therapy can just help you it can help
you set boundaries it can help you with
coping skills it can help you in all
kinds of ways and this holiday season
how about giving yourself the gift of
therapy y now if you go to
betterhelp.com that's B TT r h
lp.com
steo you get 10% off your first month I
mean you can't beat it plus you can
switch therapists at any time at no cost
and with the the simple questionnaire
they're going to match you up with the
perfect therapist for you so one more
time for 10% off your first month go to
Better Health
.c and enjoy a healthier more
comfortable you now let's get back to it
my brother and I my brother comes out of
school he's 22 I'm 33 we start this
company bayner media we start off 50-50
I had all the cred I had all the
credibility in the market I had the
money like I was the guy but I still
want 5050 because because I had just
come out of forming not resentment but I
just went through building a big company
for my dad and owning nothing mhm so so
I was overly empathetic for my brother
plus my brother I already knew was
talented and I had no clue how it was
going to play out but we did something
smart and I hope this helps someone we
said to ourselves day one we're going to
go 5050 and we have no idea what's going
to happen but whatever happens we trust
each other enough that we'll adjust in
the future to try to make it as good as
we can as good as we can or as Fair as
we can you know I would use both of
those words similar to the best of our
ability loving each other and trying to
communicate I mean let me tell you what
happened I'm hearing correctly what
you're saying we'll start 50/50 and as
we go we'll adjust it to what's
appropriate but you can't adjust it so
easily because there's tax implication
there's a lot that comes along with that
right it couldn't be like my dad my if
let's say I wasn't do anything like here
you go AJ here's 30% of the company he
has to pay taxes on it like it it it
would become so challenging so yes and
you can do that but for everyone
listening do your homework on how tax
law works and all this it's not so easy
let me tell you how it played out I
thought cuz I was the older brother and
I had other aspirations as well that I
would work with him for a while and
eventually he'd become the CEO and I'd
go do the next thing and he would run it
my brother has Crohn's disease at about
25 about three 26 about 3 four years in
maybe a little bit further five six
seven years in he has a tough uh spell
and he has to take like I think 12
inches out of his intestines has surgery
I come in and he's like yo like he's in
the hospital comes I could see he was
shook about I I don't remember perfectly
but a couple months later maybe within
the year he comes in and he says I want
out I was like [__] okay like first of
all my my I'm 11 years older than him so
first my older brother slfa and six com
in I'm like I got you then I'm like then
I settled down from that I was like yo
we need to talk about this yeah at this
point he says he wants out how big is
the company pretty big I mean it's
bottom line is I had to buy my brother
out for real
money mhm then we started a company
called Vayner Sports this is but you
have to hear the most important part of
uh of this story yes I have to buy him
out and yes I was a big impact on how
much we were doing overall and were we
5050 we were not and I feel comfortable
if AJ sat here he would say Gary did
more and was a bigger impact but then we
started Vayner Sports and to my
brother's credit Jee he's working 100%
on this I'm impacting it and recruiting
and different things like this but this
is what we're doing and look at our guys
this by the way weird moment Sidetrack
in the time of this filming the Jets
which are my entire life I love the New
York Jets more than anything are playing
the Falcons this weekend and it's the
first time my team is playing one of my
quarterbacks and I'm very weird is it
still a huge goal of yours to own the
Jets yes sir yeah anyway I'll finish
this to move on to the next part we
start this company my brother's going to
be on fulltime and I think if I remember
at the beginning I got 85% of company he
got 15 CU we were going to work on
trying to make it fair
and but he's putting in more Sweat
Equity yeah and what so how what are you
bringing to the table at 85 and he's at
15 making up for what happened on Vayner
media oh now I'm also me I [__]
recruited most of the like I'm a beast
and I'm right that's what you're
bringing to the table but but even but
to my brother's credit I want to give
him his flowers even if I never spent a
minute on this company I would own 85%
of it because that was him holding his
bargain of his word at 22 that we would
see what would happen at Vayner media
and we would always adjust and we're but
how was that conversation talking about
splitting shares at the time for this
one yeah easy because me and my brother
got lucky and I want everybody hear it
again if you feel like you have a family
member who if you set out to like We'll
always try for each other that leaves a
lot of room for you never talking to
that person again well my my people
always ask me like uh you know I have a
thing with a business partner and uh
what I say is like if if somebody ask me
if they want to go into business with a
friend or whatever I say if you're going
to do that because you have to make sure
you're operating agreement is so
explicit that everything there's a step
for anything that can [__] up cuz like
what do you do if you know he goes on
drugs yeah you got to assume the
absolute worst and address by the way
you two just crushed the [__] out of
that last you're not the bad gu both are
unbelievably right and comma so we don't
live in fantasy land and it's still
going to be gnarly no matter what you
could have the perfect plan in place
with everything covered you could assume
the worst and I promise you 9 years
later when there's real money involved
and it's not even the money it's the
feelings I [__] worked every Friday
night like like I'm even getting the
Goosebumps I always get these when I
know we're talking about something
important like just
assume and then you and then to your
point here we go we spied it out for the
last seven minutes you decide it's on
you has it worked for some yes does it
not work out for most yes and you're not
the bad guy the piece of paper is the
bad guy but you know this even with that
[__] changes a decade later like please
dude you don't understand I just had a
bad couple I went to rehab dude I'll
I'll make up for it it's like dude you
[__] and there [__] you don't think
about when you both started out as
Brothers cousins whatever you weren't in
relationships now you get married one of
the wives has a point of view on some
[__] and and by the way even if it's not
that gnarly what if it's not even weird
like the wife has a point of view two
sisters start a company the husbands get
involved and they're both beautiful
perfect marriages and and it's all good
feelings but one of the sides of the
marriages just want a different level of
work life balance with their two kids
than the other side and have different
goals and Ambitions it's all good but
what do you do now you're 50/50 and one
person's saying I want to work 9 to 5
four days a week so because I want to be
with my kids and the other side's like
whoa we're about to explode I want to
double down now it's now what now are do
you have the sh you have a shotgun
clause and you can buy out the original
like there's this is [__] it's
complicated but let me say this as
someone who's spent his whole life
working with his father and his brother
it's the [__] best when it's right
yeah but okay so here's the question no
no go ahead well I want to say Can can
you be clear to the to the audience
members or whoever you're speaking to
like don't do a handshake deal always
put it in writing right if you do a
handshake deal which I've done those
things too it will almost always end up
with anxiety at the end almost always
yeah so yes I think you're giving people
very good advice if you make a very
detailed contract you always have
something protecting the relationship
ship the paper the contract can be can
take some of the energy what's
interesting I'm saying this means Steve
have handshake deals but I'm just saying
like if you're going you guys have
confidence but it's this is a different
like like we understand each other very
well no but I'm going to say it again
you just sat here and said you
understand each other differently I just
sat here and said me and my brother
understand this is what I'm saying
there's no one- siiz fits-all are there
a billion relationships that got totally
[__] because of business yes are there
tens of thousands that work beautifully
because they underst understand each
other yes you just have to be
accountable what you are walking into
and have your eyes wide open yeah fair
enough yeah okay so the the question
that that's burning on the tip of my
tongue is uh who surfaced the number 85
and 15 so on the record it's it's good
news it's somewhere in that range by the
way it might have been 8020 I don't
recall this is 7 8 years old who surface
it I believe it went down I'm not
remembering because obviously it went so
well and easy it's not something I
remember so vividly I believe my brother
said hey of course we're g to whack this
up in a different way based on what's
been going on with Vayner media because
that's what we talked about and I think
if it happened right this second here's
what would have happened and I think
this is how it went down and I would
have said cool why don't you come to me
with what works for you and then and
then that's what I remember happening
here here's here's my uh what my tells
me please but when you're negotiating
with somebody and and you need to to
arrive at a a split um it's always G to
be better for you to to tell the person
to suggest what they're thinking and
less about the number Landing for me
I've learned even when we did Vayner
Sports which was seven or eight years
ago I've learned that money isn't my
driver because I'm capable of making it
and because I like the game more than
the trophies so it always works for me
that way because I'm less likely to be
upset about 5 or 10% less than I think I
was worth but I don't want the other
person that feel that way because they
may get [__] up because for a lot of
people they don't have the same mindset
as I
do and again here's me giving advice
that I don't take myself because I'm
always like I'll give you this yeah he
likes to give out percentages before he
sees p&l statements because I get it bro
it's I honestly bro I'm not a great
negotiator by any stretch I'm about
vibes and people and stuff like that I'm
a good businessman I'm not like whatever
but I get it I get but do you have a
shark on your team that does that for
you no but I have Mark yudkin who's my
guy he's my lawyer he's my CEO he's like
my consilier he definitely like provides
a level of even my brother represents
that for me a lot they're definitely
more straight and like try to keep it in
Pocket the problem is everybody knows
like push comes to shove I won't listen
to anybody meaning like they TR there's
been plenty of times where I'm like and
they're like dude and I'm like and I'm
like d and they're like dude and I'm
like did and they're like dude and I'm
like like you know like like now there's
also plenty of times where I'm like and
they're like dude and I'm like yeah
you're right [__] I gotta you know like
so that's how it works yeah I like well
we do that with Steve a lot but when
he's so dead set on that I honestly just
like dude well you have the vision
[__] we got you that's it and that's
it and that's it and and like this is
great I'm so pumped that a lot of people
are listening to this right now cuz this
is going on a lot right now with a lot
of people are listening they've got
their crew they're trying to figure out
these Dynamics and look I'm sure you
guys will say this and I'll say it
there's no right way there's some great
principles we've talked a lot about them
for the last 10 minutes but like
honestly let me give you the last point
on this unless you guys want to keep
talk about it just try like [__] hell
to remember you love the other person
like your boy your par like if somebody
if my dad was here and you asked him why
did you and Gary work out even though
there was potential for not to work out
family business are hard and he would
say cuz we just loved each other just a
little bit more than our feelings
towards every issue and that was right
we loved each other just a couple
percentage points more than what was
pissing us the [__] off first one the
love wins 100% love you for that that's
absolutely right yeah and when you're 90
none of this shit's going to [__]
matter when the person that you're mad
at right now is on their death bed right
it's real man like you're all mad
actually you know would be epic by the
way if anyone because of this podcast
does what I'm about to say please email
me it's Gary aters sports.com it'll be
easy to remember that
one could you imagine if somebody calls
somebody right now that they've haven't
talked to for seven years because of a
bad business breakup like a brother or
sister-in-law or Mom and reconcile their
relationship how cool is that that we
did that sure yeah um Ste was like I
don't give a
[__] do that I think that's great but
but I'm just I'm just very very fixated
on something that you just said um that
nobody's going to
none of this is going to matter when
you're 90 years old and then for me and
I know this is important to Scott as
well that come when you're 90 and and it
doesn't matter but then you die in your
life review you experience all of the uh
feelings that you caused other people in
every circumstance have you ever heard
of that like we're big into these
YouTube videos that um like near-death
experiences people people recount their
experiences having died and come back to
life and they they Life review is what
do they say they uh so they they go
through when they you know when they die
they go through the tunnel they meet
their guide or whatever and uh this is
right here that uh near-death
experiencers undergo a Life review in
which the meaning of their life is
presented to them but also how their
life affected other people as well as an
awareness of the thoughts and feelings
of those people you experience your
whole
as honestly I have literally my whole
life up until this nanc wanted to live
forever I'm so looking forward going
through that it'd be interesting when I
tell you when I die and go through it
and they review all the [__] that you
just showed me I'm going to be smiling
like a [__] I have so much more
Goodwill towards random human beings
human beings in general than anybody
I've ever met and I say this cuz it's an
outlandish statement as a compliment to
my parents predominantly my mother what
did I do they made me I am stunned on a
daily basis How Lucky I Am of how nice I
feel towards every human of all shape
sizes and angles especially in the world
we live in now where everyone's just
trying to at all cost around anything it
we ran out of [__] to be mad at each
other for religion race gen now we're on
Generations now we're teaching humans
okay hey everyone if you're in gen Z you
have to hate Boomers and hey millennials
you have to hate like I'm like watching
all this [__] and I'm like [__]
so anyway seeing this for the first time
I'm pretty fired up I'm looking forward
to it I'm going to grab some popcorn
have God show me my [__] and I think I'm
going to crush it you said you once said
something that really uh struck a chord
with me was uh I want to be remembered
for giving more than what I took when I
tell you I it similar to what we're
saying here and maybe you've heard this
as well I'm not sure I haven't said I
used to say it all the time I haven't
said it recently I literally literally
live my life based B on how many people
are going to show up to my funeral I
believe most people do not show up to
funerals unless it's really really
really that person like I think back to
my life and watching like funerals and
being like I cannot believe X wasn't
like you know like obviously like to
compel someone to go to your their
funeral you had to have a real impact
yeah like actually and like look I've
I'm very fortunate 48 I've been to I've
been unfortunately I've been to a lot of
funerals in the business world and boy
I've I remember when I was 19 I went to
this one funeral and there was like nine
people there and I was like makes sense
he just was not
nice you he laughing like it was like
Honestly though it was very real to me I
was like this guy was profoundly
successful in the business the liquor
business that I was a part of but he was
just genuinely not kind and like and I
saw it all manifested right there and
I'm like mhm I'm going to do the reverse
of this [__] yeah and I'm and I was such
a [__] I'm like and I'm going to
build a much bigger business now with
with the the This Life review thing it's
the saying is you see your life flash
before your eyes you everybody's heard
that and it's like like like all of
these people who have had near-death
experiences are are are describing the
same thing and what's crazy about it
like to make you even more excited and
maybe the rest of us less excited is
that is that the the the construct of
time is something that like only really
applies in this Physical Realm but like
on the other side the way to describe it
it's just like there's just there's not
uh uh it's not in the
confin so the detail like you can feel
like like from like the perspective of a
mosquito that's off like 300 yards over
there like the the detail like the the
the detail of the experience and without
any uh constraint of time is like so
like beyond our comprehension can you
please stop talking because I literally
like am getting too excited and I still
got a ton of [__] to to
die right and and I I I feel very
strongly that I've done more good than
bad but man do I have can I say
something that I think you'll enjoy I
think you can enjoy this cuz I think
about this as well and now you just said
it and Trigger something I am so excited
to give you this these flowers that I'm
about to give
you world living life you're a public
figure um in the business World moving
and
shaking 20 times in the last 20 years I
am so excited to tell you I love the way
people talk about you that actually know
you w cool man thank
you yeah you do good business for for
the most part and like and it's funny
it's sometimes not even like I'm very
talkative and extroverted and talk to a
lot of people even one I remember is
like how you treated someone at a
restaurant okay they told me actually
paying me a compliment comparing me to
you the way you also treated them nice
oh that's cool yeah so definitely
business like he was great on the shoes
or this and that but like people are
watching we're affecting people and not
just people that are known all of us
every human like if you're a human
walking by and another human that
doesn't have any followers or one
they're not nice you feel that it's
really funny I'm like I do this a lot
it's my natural state I've been doing it
since I was eight I really enjoy smiling
at people like it's really interesting
man like no [__] no like haaha or
whatever just like real talk like just
like seeing somebody at Dunkin Donuts
getting coffee and they're in front of
you line you just look at them you're
like like a little I like to do a little
hand wve and like people really like it
well there's some funny Reactions where
if you smile at somebody then they look
away and they they smile you no that
they're like weirded out but they look
away and they realize and then they
smile as they're looking away it's just
it's really sad like I feel like
Civility and loving your neighbor like
some of the [__] that was actually
really I've been thinking about this a
lot the last month oh [__] this this is
how I think about stuff oh [__] we've
put youth on a pedestal youth yeah these
kids know technology jenz has a say
they're going to be better than us
everyone's doing [__] OIC and and
plastic surgery trying to look younger
all this [__] they have a high sex drive
right well we like that part um and
we've really started to disrespect our
elders they don't get it they [__] up
the world for us they don't know how to
use technology and for all these years
it was the reverse right right respect
your elders I saw something that [__]
me up the other day these three kids
good dudes they weren't trying to do
they weren't like Hans but they were
just sitting on the F at the airport on
these three chairs and this 80-year-old
lady like clearly was looking for a I
was on the phone having a business call
but I was watching it and I was like
dude how the [__] is nobody getting up
for this lady and like that would have
never happened in 1954 every [__]
person
yeah done the other thing too is that
old people serve as a reminder of our
mortality and if we don't want to think
about our mortality I think there's some
validity to that I just think we
underestimate wisdom sure I just think
we do okay how about this um the uh the
the idea of having children yes you know
back in the in the beginning of the
country and and in in in work on the
farm times yeah we needed them workers
yeah you needed workers and you wanted
to have more children
so that when you in your like end of
your life you would have these children
to care for you it was you were setting
yourself up with caregivers that's right
and somewhere along the line I'm going
to guess it was somewhere between the
Boomers and the Gen xers Y that uh that
that that that shifted to where children
uh were no longer uh future caregivers
they the children became really
expensive pets
and that's all it is a kid is like you
have a have children now you've got
really expensive pets yes that you have
to take care of at fully into their
adulthood like I saw I saw
statistic um in
1940 um like over uh over
90% of every kid
um would uh more successful than than
their parents then in 1980 that became a
50/50 coin flip 1980 it became a 50-50
coin so what is it now what percentage
do you think of Jen ear have 15 I that's
a general CH area oh we're GNA find out
what more
success do better than their parents you
know
um oh with jenzi most likely to say
they're doing better than their parents
okay that doesn't tell us anything well
yeah what were um did you have a stat in
mind that you're G to say I I don't know
I only know I only all I saw was 1940 I
think what you're saying is like cuz
most genz are like dude I can't even
afford a [__] house now well right I
mean and that's the thing like I got a
vasectomy because uh you know multiple
reasons but very major uh influence on
me getting the sectomy was what I
considered to be just dwindling
opportunity like they you hear people
say the American dream uh you know isn't
what it would used to be yeah you know
I'm a I'm more optimistic than that I by
the way I understand all of that and
there's plenty of validity to have that
conversation I think there's a couple
problems first I think it's hypocrisy
let me explain you have all these gen Z
kids saying like [__] my parents they
[__] up [__] and they're 24 and
they're on the payroll
right like like so first it's really s
hard to say well I can't do it or this
sucks and you're not changing the
narrative for yourself meaning our lack
of patience of eating [__] for a period
of time to get to where we want to get
to is Gone Gone Gone the reason so many
people were able to make it was you
thought that it would take 15 years for
you to make it MH now you tell someone
who's 21 it's going to take 15 days to
make it way and they're like nah man I
ain't got that time like bro all you got
is time now couple things one I'm
generalizing I've met an ungodly amount
of 18 to 22 year olds who are on fire
who want to [__] do it plenty of that
but it has become because some people
popular culture is [__] up people
because Mark Zuckerberg could in seven
years because of the internet get to a
trilly everyone's like yo you know the
top 1% in America the richest country in
the world the top 1% make 650,000 a year
a lot of money but every kid that's 19's
like if if you tell them well you're
only going to make a million a year
they're like damn I suck they think it's
like so easy it's impossible YouTube
influencer money that's right and so
every everyone's confused so couple
things I get that I understand why
that's happening separation of wealth is
an issue it's all Roman Empire [__] but
here's my thing as a human don't be
discouraged meaning okay the American
treat listen I love America I immigrated
here from the Soviet Union I [__]
love this place but really as a human
it's all about accountability if someone
if I was 19 and somebody told me bro 10
years from now it's a wrap nothing can
happen here my next question would be
like where does it happen MH and if they
were like Australia I'd be like let's
[__] go like like to me it's like
okay like Honestly though it's like I
there's always an option like I'm so
pumped next year's an election year
mainly because everyone's going to be un
ansted and all my buddies and friends
and acquaintances and business
associates are all going to say the same
dumb [__] if x or y whichever one of the
two wins I'm leaving I've been hearing
this for 20 years there's not a
[__] that moved to Canada yeah
yeah their website crashed the night of
the election and then nobody ever moved
do you uh do you want to be in the
frying pan or the fire this time
around neither neither neither the the
ice box eating some I think 2024 is
going to be a good year because I think
the fed's going to start dropping the
rate because it's an election year
Bitcoin having I think the crypto
markets are going to start popping off
so then the real estate where you at
with the real estate market if they're
going to be dropping the rates do you
think though that there's going to be
more inventory I don't one thing I like
is I speak with a ton of conviction of
what I know and I tread lightly where I
don't know don't know real estate I
watch it I'm human being I like business
I like pop culture it's all part of it
but no I don't have the expertise I
think what I do have is I'm good at
history and of course to your point if
interest rates start coming down [__]
starts to happen of course people aren't
going to buy [__] when money's got an 8%
big on it and it did like like this is
very historical um there's also Trend
changing meaning shit's changing like
where people want to live how people
want to live now it's Zoom life like
it's like when some kid the other day
said Gar I'm just gonna live around the
world and do all my meetings and I'm
like I get it they can and they can I'm
like I get it I'm like yeah you like man
life yeah bro like I'm like I get it
like like like to me everything's like
why not like everyone wants to look at
yesterday without understanding where
tomorrow's going like why can't you be
Aid and by the way once you make that
shift the places you can live if you
love the outdoors and you're a little
bit more Rural and stuff like that like
some of the [__] like sometimes I get
weird and just Google [__] I'm like 900
acres in weird in like weird do it right
now 900 acres in Pennsylvania like watch
this right right you ever do this Zillow
porn yeah it's like it's like just click
anything like I don't know there you go
the first one I don't give a [__] pay
the [__] ad fee lamb.com
um like some of this [__] play figure it
out I believe you you've been very good
at navigating this he's a he's a genzer
look at this this shit's crazy to me
here we go 845
Acres look at
this 88 now that's 11 do do me what I'm
looking for find me like three acres for
like $4 go like least
price 800 acres for million two that's
like 800 soccer
fields that's crazy isn't this like I
look at this stuff so I think about
somebody who loves the woods actually
let's just use this 878 acres in Alabama
you got it right there bottom left third
fourth one down if you don't mind with
the river not that one go down left down
down right there that's pretty the creek
let's just look at this for a second
look $3.5 million is a ton of money
let's put things in perspective comma
878 Acres so if you're someone who
genuinely loves that
life and you needed and you wanted to
live in New York City and work in New
York City and to get this kind of thing
you had to go to the Hamptons where it
cost $8 million for a half an acre or
you could just chill in [__] odv
Alabama where the [__] this is and have
878 hunt every day work live off the
[__] food in the land and the whole
that [__] and but you could go on Zoom
all day from your [__] and that goes
for San Diego and that goes for some
tropical place that we could probably
Google Now like the world's changing and
I love that and so I'm not like honestly
I'm not worried about my mom made more
money than me or the American Dreams
done here's the punchline the American
dream has been going on for a 100 years
and there's been unlimited [__]
who've been
losing more than 100 years that's
250 but branded brand as the American
dream branded all right and during that
time steo unlimited dudes and GS were
losing mhm the American dream was
opportunity now it's going away there
will be unlimited opportunity for people
in America and everywhere else the
question becomes what are you going to
do about it because I promise you if you
stand all day and Google and go through
your feed and completely believe that
your generation can't have it as good as
your parent generation well then it's a
wrap and it's already over yeah I like
that
I I I like that a lot man let me uh let
let me ask you this you find what you're
looking for you want to say the world's
all [__] up I can show you 900 things
right now on the internet and you're
right you want to say the world's
awesome I can show you 900 things and
tell you the problem is 95% are in that
first part right now is that victim
mentality 100% it's all perception it's
easier it's easier to be a victim than
you have to do [__] about it well feels
good to point people love a good [__]
point yeah um he's getting too super
into it yeah look at him he just forgot
he was on the
van yeah let me let me ask you this cuz
I know a lot I think a lot of people are
always learning you know H how did you
how did you know this my my biggest
question in my 20s were like dude these
[__] millionaire like how did they
how do they know this and and I started
you know reading Tony Robbins books or
or Rich Dad Poor Dad and then I started
say well how did they know that and then
I kept tracing it back to well they all
got their information from Napoleon
Hills thinking rich and that's my
favorite book and it's it's the
bestselling self-help book of all time
love it do you have uh a book no that's
not how I I don't I've learned that I
don't have I have real uh reading
comprehension issues I was an ' 80s kid
so I didn't get diagnosed but I don't
read books what what I've learned from
is the market but how but I'll explain
yeah it
it so where you were going yeah I can't
explain explain to you why at 6 or 7
when it snowed in Jersey and everybody
started building a snowman and sledding
that I wanted to get a shovel and ring
doorbells and be like can I shovel your
driveway for five bucks nobody taught
you that nobody taught me that my dad my
mom was an 80s mom just go outside and
play it was very cool it was awesome and
my dad was never around worked which I
respect the [__] I'm saying that in a
good way like he was building our
family's life it was just naturally in
My DNA I was like I was actually
genuinely I think truly entrepreneurial
it was just my makeup but what taught me
all what I learned was the doorbell
ringing was the baseball card shows was
stocking the shelves at my dad's store
I'm inherently curious and I pay
attention so even as young as like 12
doing baseball card shows when when
someone's like how much is that I was
like oh this Cal Ripkin junior is 20
bucks and they'd be like oh N I would
always analyze what went down when I
would ring doorbells as a kid no I
remember not just being like scared most
people are scared to get the no which is
why I don't do it I was even not only
not scared I was always like fascinated
by like what did I say how did I say I
was very introspective so I think a lot
of mine was natural and then what I was
learning was learning on the job as you
hear people talk about anything in life
so I'm a better learner living it than I
am reading it and I think a lot of
things came natural which is why I
actually think my platform has played
out the way it is I think when I hit the
scene a decade ago and I was like okay
now let me give the game to the kids I
was saying it's so different and saying
different [__] because I think I did it
a different way and so like I'm very
grateful for being like I feel like I
feel I can I can step out of my ownself
and be like oh okay Gary you you were
pretty you were original enough that
that it brought but it was based on I'm
sure if I read those books i' like oh
[__] yeah they knew like I never think I
do I don't think anything I do is new
I'm sure and I promise you long before
Napoleon Hill like somebody like well
yeah cuz his whole thing was he he hung
around with like the billionaires of
like the 1900s and he studied their
thing and he wrote it into a principal
but the like the billionaires knew and
he and they exactly I think there's
Universal truths to like hustle hustle
muscle and and hustle muscle is you know
and now we've like made cancelled I mean
that was such a pain in the ass that's
canceled yeah like can hustle muscle
hustle it's like a bad like that because
people turned it into
burnout
and like re and honestly and I get it by
the way nobody wants I like how trains
popped up for hustle musle um uh yeah
well dude look at this kid that the
universal truths of work ethic are real
it well they're they come from somewhere
Network networking is real like people
[__] make [__] happen yeah like you
know like uh I I think a big one that is
not tell me if I'm wrong you I I like
that you know some of this stuff well I
think humility is a big one of course I
think humility is like it's not like
what dudes want to talk about enough I
think humility is a [__] superpower
like if you don't get high on your own
Supply it's just enjoyable people will
could because you reach a certain level
and so many people are insecure they
start talking [__] about people because
they got somewhere and it [__] you up
like I think genuine humility is a beast
of ail
like I think 100% yeah I mean I never
want a bus tables again I I love that
and I love um I think it's less of being
scared of going there it's more of like
no look we've been fortunate the three
of us right worked for that I don't
think like I'm got lucky like of course
you get lucky that you didn't die or you
were born at all like you could I don't
like when people weaponize luck so that
they don't have to do [__] no but of
course we're fortunate but we've worked
hard and we're here right but the
reality is is that once you get there
how you act is like incredibly
fascinating to me I mean look you guys
know you guys have been around like
watching I I hate that people don't
understand that money and fame they
don't change you they expose you they uh
yeah yeah I I I couldn't agree more it
uh it it
um emphasizes it uh exaggerates it uh
magnif it magnifies your tra it exposes
you 100% I'm telling you it just does
I've just met too many people I've been
around too long now it's too obvious if
you were a great dude before it happened
and you get money you become a really
great dude if you were miserably hurting
inside and the way you got successful
there's only two ways to get successful
deep deep conviction gratitude like
happiness or the reverse deep anxiety
and negga like I'm going to show you
[__] everyone like they are
superpowers ooh I definitely it's Star
Wars it's like the dark side and the
Jedi are super close and the Jedi are
just going to win by just a little bit
like plenty people make money because of
Darkness it's just hard to sustain it
once you're there yeah I remember in my
20s I would go to I would go to bed
every night see you like that well I I
do because um when uh when I was
dropping out of the University of Miami
in
1993 I had been dumped by this girl she
said she was looking into her future she
couldn't see me in it she wanted to be
successful in life she wanted to have
stuff she thought I was going to be a
loser like it it it really really I
really understand where she was coming
from well there was no precedent for
what I was trying to do she like like
you're talking you're talking about
you're going to become a crazy famous
stunt man with a video camea like I
don't get it I really do like I mean it
this goes back to how the world works
but go ahead I I don't this I don't get
it like I just I can't you know like and
were you in love and I mean you had a
big crush on her she she had been my
girlfriend and I mean I don't know like
week but a year that's long time oh a
year W in that in that time of your life
the year is like everything yeah yeah I
mean a whole semester and then we were
apart for the summer like uh don't
downplay it fans he was super in love
you could see it it was his first love
Yeah was it your was in bed yeah right
and and so and and nothing what's her
name her name was Tracy and there's
nothing wrong last nameid there's
nothing wrong I'm not desar was right
Tracy was right she wanted better for
herself and and she had to have a
boundary and and and me I was blowing it
I was blowing it I I wasn't going to
class I was drunk all the time I failed
out I got kicked out she couldn't have
been more right but it hurts so much to
be told that she thought I was just
going to be a loser in life that like
when that when I when I proceeded on
with the video camera and trying to do
the
stunts every year Tracy received a VHS
tape of how badass like my my the the
the filming that I did like each year
the the tape that I mailed to Tracy got
more and more bad ass how long are you
doing that for I what started in last
week yeah
started
she just got the buck in
the it it started like when uh I mean
she she dump me in
1993 I certainly uh was presenting
footage to her like whenever I had the
chance in person like uh mailed a tape
in 1996 1997 19 like uh by by 1998 like
uh there were actual like professional
Graphics baked in because I was showing
up in like and and so like I I I just so
genuinely it resonated with you when
you're like [__] you know and I'll show
you fun it's funny wow when you told
that story like the way I would think
about I don't have that same gear but
when I do think about trying to have
that gear or like what would I do in
that gear I wouldn't have gone I would
have gone the other way I think the more
gangster version is nothing and just
know you're going to get that Outreach
in 10 years that Outreach long that long
game like I've gotten some fun
outreaches when I was started to pop 10
15 years ago and it was deliciously
satisfying yeah yeah but it's okay to
get like motivation out of SP out of
spite and look but I do think I will say
this brother and I think it's fair but I
will say this because I really am
fascinated by this subject matter I tell
everybody who's motivated by Spite try
to tweak it because when it is your
driver when you get there it's not like
like like when I hear that he's also a
humorous dude like sure like to your
point I think the way you're saying just
make sure it's not 100% spite cuz when
it's 100 100% spite when it's that pure
Darkness it gets dark when you get there
totally yeah I I just mean by like like
this one chick broke up with me and I
was like oh I just want to get better
looking and just like also for my health
and like to look better on camera and
all that stuff but it was like just like
no I want to show her that like what
she's missing what am I seeing your eyes
right are your eyes that pretty yeah
they're pretty pretty my
God was like listen I was like listening
to him talk and I was like man he's got
some pretty [__] up fall over head
over heels dude eyes and he's like it's
the eyes
dude guys I'm telling you it's eyes I'm
so blown away that people have not
figured this out we need to do a lot
like all these people are trying to look
good I'm like man if they just realized
it's that you should do a little contact
lenses like the eyes are the eyes are
the game to the dude I'm tell thank you
Gary close I'm pretty far away right now
and they were just like they were
glowing from here I was like no I think
they're pretty thank you light eyye dark
hair thing is real yeah it's very
Eastern European of you Vinnie yeah
thanks Scott I think that I think that
there's so much Merit so much value in
that and and if I'm honest I absolutely
was like I wanted to show show her I to
show everybody I wanted to show
everybody and it's been a huge help for
me like in in standup like oh people
don't want I want to show them I'm going
to show for me that's like a healthy
spite it is and for me what was
interesting was back to some of the
stuff we just talked brother I've been
curious the whole time to me it's like
how big can I make this it's been a very
like almost like an curious engineer I
say in my head sometimes I'm like I like
it because I'm I really want to make my
parents proud that that I've realized is
a big one that's a big driver for me
making them proud like real like even
now like I can already start to like
feel getting a little you know like I I
love it I I'm so grateful thank God they
got me I was born literally in the least
entrepreneur oral place on Earth for all
the kids that are listening the USSR was
like North Korea you weren't allowed to
leave I was literally born in a
country a communist country that you
weren't allowed to leave like America
passes some like weird like like
California New York pass like some
subtle law and they're like social no no
I grew up in real socialism like and so
like I'm so grateful so hey I know I'm
driven that I want to make them proud
which is awesome but I am I become very
curious on the Merit on the blue ocean
thing I'm a big thinker of like a big
believer not thinker big believer of
like to build the biggest building in
town there's two ways to do it either
you just are capable of building it or
you spend your time tearing it down
everybody else's buildings and I watch
people and they really like number two
they build a decent sized building and
then they spend all their energy [__]
tearing everybody else's down and I'm
just kind of on like how Okay 40 stories
50 stories 70 you know like I sit here
just turned 48 Real Talk guys real talk
I know we're just getting to know each
other I'm like I'm just starting yeah
sure like of course I know I've done
[__] but like I've got juice for these
next 30 40 MH like and and not like
because I want just cuz why wouldn't I
want to
play you can't see yourself retiring no
I really can't ever no and and only
because whatever I would do instead of
building companies is not as fun the way
someone loves golf or sailing or cooking
like I like I like what I'm doing right
now more than those things I don't want
to go water skiing like [__] your golf
clubs like like this is more fun I'll go
garage sailing yeah but yeah no I I
don't want to not retire because I want
to make more or like whatever like it's
just fun pure bread anything pure bread
comic purebred mother purebred teacher
guidance counselor sailor plumber like
pure bread is pure bread I am a pure
bred entrepreneur there's nothing more
fun to me than doing stuff in business
it's super fun and it's not about the
money like it's just not yeah I'm a pure
bread attention [__] I get it yeah
we're getting Stephen to the affiliate
marketing game so I've been researching
all that kind of [__] that's going to be
exciting next chapter make sure that the
only thing in that game is make sure you
believe in what you're selling sure yeah
that's the big one that's where that
gets [__] up you got there's like you
got to really find it yeah no we we made
a cool list of like things that he
actually uses and stuff so that and they
by the way you know what's going to be
huge is finally it looks like I've been
waiting for this it finally looks we're
in a presus in America of of live
shopping so in China for the last decade
all the all the social networks live
shopping is a
monster like you're going through and
you're picking out actually virtually no
nope Q
QVC like video on I mean um on the man
put uh live shopping China uh lady with
handbags there's something that went
pretty viral recently this is the most
insane video I've seen let's see
this take out China cuz it might have
just been you're thinking so you're
saying like like QVC but on your phone
I'm saying Tik Tok live I I'm saying my
man right here oh like social media yeah
and Tik tok's already doing that didn't
Tik Tok just start that um is doing it
everyone's going to do it I believe that
St as you go through your experimenting
of affiliate because I'm getting a sense
of you got some chops you're gonna be
like wait a minute [__] affiliate links
let's go live on Tik Tok for two hours a
day and sell
[__] all right that'd be interesting
hell yeah dude well dude this is this is
epic and and here we're like it's live
put live shopping it's less selling it's
live
shopping on social
China China China yeah in China the
future of shopping is already happening
that's right this whole phenomenon this
I think you would crush because you're
actually entertaining and you're
actually talented and and and like by
the way I'll just do it right now one of
the ways I was going to tell you to
explode the living [__] out of this is
to set up a Tik Tok shop and go on Tik
Tok for an hour a day and just [__]
doing what you guys do best you will be
flabber of what's going to happen and
flabbergasted I have no idea what I just
said flabbergasted uh yeah this this
this phenomenon is coming and it's
coming fast but do you think but do you
think like with Tik Tok yes it becoming
this live shopping thing it's going to
kill the whole creative NP like posting
I believe in the world of and there's
enough for everybody Vinnie you know
what I mean Vinnie like do I believe
that the hours spent on do I I believe
the hour someone's going to watch steo
and and you three selling this joking
around trying different dishes bringing
on people with their products to like
put it on does that hour come away from
somebody scrolling in feed and maybe
watching a 30-minute video of me or
something else sure but that's going on
every day every hour right I mean it's
it's either that or they're going to
watch someone play a video game no look
what's happening there where it's kind
of been happening this is coming to
America and it's going to be [__] bad
bananas and you guys I'm kind of pumped
right now that we stumbled into this
combo cuz I'm convinced in a year one of
you is going to DM me or text me it'll
chop it up and you'll be like holy [__]
dude that's how big this is going to be
now how do you know especially for
someone like you who can actually do
[__] some people suck dick on camera
yeah yeah yeah yeah but okay how they
not going to sell [__] Vinnie how are
you so you will cuz they're just going
to zoom in on your eyes and people are
going to be like I'll take five because
he recognizes patterns that's what I was
going to ask because like you you
predicted like Facebook
youed what
thing very good at this because I put in
the work I pay attention I've been
watching this [__] since 2018 yeah like
I'm like like I don't know like it's
what we do with our time nature follows
P but how could how could I help me
understand how could a pattern predict
Facebook's gonna buy Instagram Mark
Zuckerberg at I'm trying to think what
he did before he bought Instagram that
tipped me off to it well he has to yeah
but that's revisional history like at
the time like it was just like you know
at the time what I knew was that Mark
was looking at all things that had
attention not just Facebook did he tried
to buy maybe he tried to buy Twitter I
think that's it I think Mark tried to
buy Twitter I just could see by his
patterns that he got the two
entrepreneurs that I most pegged were
Bezos and Zuck because they I just
understood what they were doing Bezos
was doing how I built my dad's store
customer over everything I cared about
nothing I cared about my employees only
because I knew that would help me care
about my customers and I could give a
[__] about anything else profit margin
what me whatever me and my dad made I
knew that if I was obsessed with it's
what I do now yeah like people people
make fun of me all I'm writing a new
book called day trading attention it's G
to come out next year Vinnie I swear to
God I'm putting out literally every
secret I'm this Tik Tok thing right now
like my friends make fun of me of doing
[__] like this like why are you telling
them it's back to the blue ocean I'm
like cuz I'm going to get mine mhm and
honestly I like I like that somebody's
going to email me in 9 months it's going
to say steo podcast I'm going to click
and read him like yo never heard of you
actually I did see you actually I
thought you were a dick face before you
were on steveo's podcast like I saw you
say something I didn't like it I
listened I liked it it was a cool show
and then I heard the Tik Tok thing and I
started selling my [__] skateboards
on it and like oh my God I have $600
like it's [__] awesome for me I love
aren't motivated so even if you give
them an idea they're not going to use it
not everyone not but but like to your
point
as long as one person yeah to me it's
like I'm with you brother I'm with you
so much comma you weren't until you
were I always was
respect but I was trying to follow your
story where you said that like you
started to build more momentum so maybe
it was well I always had the drive and I
always was like I will work for free for
the next 50 years to make it this this
is why you and I get along like work
look like work ethic matters to your
point everybody's trying to figure out a
way to make work ethic not part of it it
will always be part of it my point is
well then do something you love when
steo said this and and Tracy yeah said
you're not going to make it I get it
Tracy didn't have the understanding that
the genre of entertainment he was doing
was about to pop we grew up in an era
where a lot of our friends were amazing
at video games on Nintendo and Atari and
television and Sega Genesis but none of
us were like hey bro keep at it you
might be the [__] Tony Hawk of video
games in 20 we didn't think that
that I didn't see yeah didn't because I
wasn't thinking that way I see all those
things like so what happened was to his
point I'm very good at pattern
recognition I'm very good at popular
culture history you know what's funny I
had dinner with Tommy Mata the other
night and he was telling about his
career and I was like oh I see what he
did he knew what happened in the 50s and
60s Frank Sinatra did A Christmas album
let me tell Mariah Cary to do it because
it makes sense Christmas Al you just
keep playing you keep playing them you
keep playing them right like this time
of year like and he just did he did
Selen Deion's residency at Vegas yeah of
course he did that's what the [__]
rap pack did in the 60s he was good at
rebooting [__] I'm good at rebooting
[__] when I see twitch um or when I see
social media I'm like yeah that was MTV
when MTV first came out it was like [__]
what the [__] is cable there's three
channels what HBO was fledging MTV was
play you know like MTV actually worked
right out the gate but what MTV was in
the 80s and 90s is what Tik Tok is now
it's just the place where kids attention
is
everything's going to be player one
ready I can't wait that's what it'll be
like right digital currency people are
going to be in their headsets I think I
think I think VR is real it to be yeah
it's G be 20 years but it's real like if
I if I want to sit into a therapist
office but she's in New York I'm going
to get on the VR and have a therapy
session like I mean that's you're pretty
much already there with that you just
took the [__] words out of my mouth
perfect job good work yeah but cuz
they're gateways Zoom is the middle step
to that yeah I mean you could put on an
Oculus right now go zoom.com yeah the
only problem is one day the Oculus will
look like this and you're just like
hello you're reading AR like even better
one day Oculus is going to look like
this like like a contact yeah like have
you seen the movie Aon not buten I know
the punch line I mean you're walking
down the street and it's just like a
digital profile everybody walks by AR is
amazing AR is [__] amazing by the way
the new rayb band meta Facebook thing oh
where you could just hit the uh dude
it's [__] fresh the fact that they
did that from one year to the next year
and you don't need ears it's going to
speed up I love when people think that
the moment they're living in is when
technology stops no no I'll go for this
iPhone is going to look like a [__]
beeper in 20 years for sure yeah well
it's going to be the once neurolink
takes off if it does like that's going
to be a game changer but I it it would
be weird to implant a chip into your
brain I would do it would you let me
tell you when I would do it I would do
it I'm a second wave guy I wouldn't be
the first first dude to do it cuz I'm
like what's up with the cancer but if
you gave me a few minutes of it and I
understood I'm definitely not going to
be the hold out like I'm going like why
not yeah like I don't know like where do
you a chip in your brain that's kind of
weird concept I get it but like people
put [__] in their heart and that was a
weird concept to people 70 years ago
yeah when people were like yo we can fix
everyone was dying of heart attacks back
in the day and then they're like we're
going to cut you open and put a [__]
thing on your heart I would have been
like [__] you yeah at Amazon when you
could pay with your pal at first I was
like [__] that saw that for the first
time yesterday I want everyone to know
everything I want everything to be
frictionless I was like of course
blockchain wait to deep fake videos come
out do you understand that we just did a
full pledge interview and in four years
kids are going to [__] around and change
the [__] we said on this and it's going
to look like we said it well have you
seen them on Tik Tok they're taking
aren't they already doing that they're
doing that with ran podcast they're like
hey my dick got bigger but it's like him
and but they're changing his voice to
sell their product that's right so what
happened is the last 100 years video has
been I would argue video has been the
judge and jury of our society if you see
it on video happened JFK did get
assassinated Rodney K get did get beat
like the Yankees did like video was the
proof we're about to go into the era of
where you don't believe a single video
over the next decade all the videos
we're not going to see and then people
going to understand why the blockchain
matters because this episode in a three
years you're not going to post on
YouTube first you're going to post on
your blockchain address first iio that's
right to show that this was real and
then go up and then when I find on the
internet I don't know if this doesn't
exist yet from my knowledge base they're
going to connect those two things the
blockchain's about to get uncomfortably
uncomfortably important cardono baby all
the way to the Moon do you see what the
that's the for what the what the
blockchain does is nobody owns the
service everyone everyone's like America
China Russia everyone's like Facebook
Tik Tok all controlled now good good
news there's something called the
blockchain nobody controls the servers
that's the place of Truth and obviously
the nft craziness of two summers ago
that happened just like internet stocks
in in the first wave people got crazy
cuz this new thing things get overvalued
because greed and Ridiculousness takes
over it gets reconnected corrected
excuse me and then you start to build
the aftermath of the 2000 stock crash of
all the internet companies was 99% of
the huers went away and went back to
Banking and being a lawyer and the 1%
that actually gave a [__] built the
Amazon and the paypals and the ebays and
the [__] that [__] actually mattered
here's the pattern of how I know
blockchain is going to pop off is when
you start seeing sign that says we are
no longer a cashless cash business
that's right you're like well what is it
it's like oh they want you on your phone
well it's so funny a buddy of mine was
like really passionate like a year and a
half ago when this combo was hot he's
going to get me at dinner and he goes
into he would [__] I felt like he did
a l a lot of homework I was proud of him
like some good points he goes how could
you trust it like how do you know that's
your cash how can you trust it you have
to hold it and I was like I was like
what's in your pocket and he's like what
and he like like so got his wallet out I
go that's a credit card how do you trust
that I'm like do you understand this the
same conversation that happened in 1960
when people were talking about credit
cards are coming and all these could you
imagine dudes in the 60s all those
characters with real money like [__] you
it's all cash I don't want people
knowing my [__] cash cash cash I mean
there's still people like that today of
course but but today like it's I laugh
when people like well how do you know
where your money is I'm like where's
your money right now yeah where the
[__] your money right now losing 7%
under your mattress a year crazy yeah
[__] t- bills now like it's crazy
like it's a it's listen all this shit's
interesting first of all I just want to
say not that I'm wrapping it up I still
got time but I'm enjoy I'm enjoying the
[__] out of this but yeah I I I got to
pee like crazy and uh we crush it we've
been doing it for a while I know we we
got an hour and a half oh we [__]
annihilated I think this is good think a
lot to ask of the audience if you went
Coast to Coast I [__] love you dude I
say that at the end of every episode
episode I say our street team to the
street team well we should give away
something on your website for the people
that are listening to the very end you
want to do something um oh I like that
little call to add give away something
uh you want to I'll give some I would
like to um how about how about I create
a a a special URL and and put the bucket
list on there for free whoa like uh just
real quick like you got to be the first
people to this
you g do it for like a week you know
what that's gonna get me a breach of
contract I'll I'll jump in all right go
I'll jump in you guys create a URL you
can post produce this afterwards but you
get me the the 25 people that did it
their name and address and I'll just
send them a ton of [__] we could do that
too we could do that go to the bottom
Sur surprise boxes go to the bottom of
sto.com love it and uh with the on the
on the customer support just say Gary ve
is going to send me some [__] and title
yeah yeah in your title and then leave
your your your name and address and the
first 25 people people that that if this
has been up for more than two hours the
ship is yeah the ship is sa proba sa
you're probably number
26 right that's great for a creating
incentive for people to get on it
quicker so that everybody wins it's just
fun like so fun just nice to do fun [__]
by the way Tik Tok live I'm telling you
right now here's why first of all Let Me
Tell let me I'm just going to add a
little more value Instagram live you go
on Instagram pings the people that
follow you they all come on and then as
I'm sure you know it decreases over time
right because everyone comes they get
ping and and they decrease makes sense
like an email like fine they see what's
going on okay I've seen yeah they hang
for as long as they can and they got a
bounce but because you had a full flood
and it declines Tik Tok goes the other
way Tik Tok the longer you're on the
more they're s surfacing your live even
non-followers too right especially
non-followers yeah
Instagram doesn't even do that Instagram
doesn't do non-followers so so you go on
for an hour you guys do what you got a I
mean this is the last thing you guys
have to worry about yeah it's all going
to be predicated on good ideas fun ways
to do it you have unlimited ways
everything from just wanting to do it by
yourself for an hour and talk about it
to like you producing cool ideas I don't
have any worry about that but you do it
a lot here's the best part also then you
get to chop up little pieces from it
where there's Tik Tok will show you
where the spikes were of
you clip it and you run those as Tik Tok
and Instagram and Facebook and YouTube
short ads to sell the stuff so you're
basically creating a production day to
create good ads while you're selling
[__] on a Tik Tok live it's crazy it's
[__] crazy you're basically let me
use it in old school terms you're
basically doing a QVC show that's
randomly showing up to people who don't
know who you are and for that you get to
see the data that shows you what
commercials you should make for your
product on all the other platforms
that's great wow that's great are you
are you still on the same tip as uh um
posting as much as you can all day every
day yeah I think I think this like
push-ups if you do 30 push-ups you get
30 push-up results yeah you do 100
push-ups you get 100 now what people
don't hear what I say it back to things
I say that maybe I need to do a better
job breaking down which is why I'm
writing this book or I or I'm hoping
people can hear what I'm saying when I
say post 30 times a day I'm also saying
post on seven platforms yes and I'm also
saying tweak it slightly based on a
platform so for example I think y'all
should should post a lot more on
LinkedIn that doesn't seem native or
natural but meanwhile LinkedIn is
getting a ton of organic reach and
because most of it is business content
but people are in it all day long now
like Facebook anything that's somewhat
out of the ordinary does even better and
let's call it spade a spade a lot of
people in LinkedIn are in their 40s and
50s who are like real fans of you it's
like a good demo for you wow so like so
all a sudden think about 30 now 30 post
day all of a sudden if you're just
posting on Instagram and YouTube that's
like 30 a day that's [__] up but when
you're posting on are you guys posting
on Snapchat
Spotlight there you go I know trust me I
know I'm watching everything Snapchat's
got unbelievable reach if you know what
you're doing YouTube shorts versus just
YouTube LinkedIn is now if you say when
you know what you're doing like are
there different strategies for like
different from Snapchat content strategy
is the hardest marketing craft in the
world YouTube shorts is where it's at
Gainer media yeah but that's super
expensive and for big companies that's
why I'm trying to put out as much that's
why every five or 10 I wrote a book
about 10 years ago called jab jab jab
right hook and to this day I get 10
emails a day like head of marketing this
marketing that entrepreneur like that
book and I I went like a huge rally of
it a couple months ago just randomly
just hearing from a lot of people of how
much that book changed her life and I
was like man how are and then even new
people like I just read it it's so great
I'm like [__] man it's so outdated so I
started writing a new book called jab
jab jab left hook oh great but then when
I went through it I realized this is
much more complex so it's it's been
renamed to day trading attention because
that's what I do I day trade attention
I'm giving you platform strategy right
now but I'm also paying attention to
everything that's happening in pop
culture why are people wearing corduroy
hats why did Alex Earl pop on Tik Tok
why did liquid death work who's the
upand cominging rapper what food is
working like shoes sneakers like why
like like why did vans cross over from
skateboard West Coast kids to black kids
in the Urban world like why why why why
so I live in that both on platform and
on culture once you understand those
things you can
dominate okay wow all right let's
dominate yeah I love it dude thank you
man thank you for oh yeah yeah dude that
was that was
rad how'd you like that Gary ve I mean
dude guy's got energy he's got Charisma
man and he's got energy I really like
like them too I thought that was great I
didn't know what I was getting into and
and uh I fell in love with them and you
know it's long time ago I fell in love
with every single one of you the
beautiful people who stick around to the
very end of the Wild Ride podcast and
let me also tell you guys that I see on
Twitter and Instagram and stuff when
when you guys post your like end of year
Spotify wrap up like my top podcast and
like it it moves me it it just it warms
my heart so much because like I I'm
really I get sensitive with like like
negative comments if I see them like
they have so much power over me and uh
when I see those Spotify things and and
I know you guys are out there like that
means everything to me so an extra
special thank you for being the street
team I love you guys and have happy
holidays yeah
dude